what is happening there citizens of
the reject Nation we got ourselves
an official trailer for Five Nights at
Freddy's we're running late to this one
uh it's not John's fault but I gotta
blame him for some reason John why'd
you make us late because I'm too scared
and I don't want to have nightmares G
I wish I didn't say yeah for this I don't
really have a good back and forth here guys
leave a like on this video if you're excited
for Five Nights at Freddy's also if you didn't
catch the memo John Coy and myself we are
going to be having a panel at Comic-Con
where we won't be talking about Five Nights
at Freddy's but it'll be the Saturday July
22nd either way if you're going to be attending
Comic-Con would love to have you in attendance
in our whole audience section that would be
lovely anywho guys let's get to it thank you
hi this is Mike I was just calling to see if that
job that you offered was still available yeah
yeah the security guard I will take anything
this place was huge in the 80s with the kids
they shut it down years ago the owners just
not ready to let it go yet I will work
and you will sleep I understand oh no
gonna put their child in danger
just keep your eyes on the monitor nice welcome
to Freddy Fazbear's we're
fantasy and fun come to life
oh no we must be new security guards can I uh help
you officer have you met them yet I don't know who
them they're here
wow
awesome oh damn they really
brought them to life yeah
in the 80s kids went missing
Freddy's top to bottom hello and
find nothing they never found them
that's why the play shut down
children possessing dying robots
ghost children thanks for the heads
up technically they're animatronics
what do they want they want to make her like them
Bobby oh I love that they've really brought
them their life so accurately oh it's too late
Bobby go
this looks intense
I wanna play a game where
two no no where are those no
damn he's getting out he's getting out yeah
outbreak into the real world all right well
I enjoy that trailer quite a bit I must say
that was real enjoyable cheesy camp but it
also looks really great I mean the animatronics
look awesome here they they feel like genuinely
practical like do we know what who made them do
you know I don't know what what effects house
or you know but uh you guys know who made them
but it seems like they're perfectly arranged for
this because you know in the games obviously
it's it's the look and they're rendered in 3D
so yeah it's like the perfect way to bring them
to life because they look exactly like the game
but they also look real yeah I love I love the
SX and that's probably the most important thing
you got to capture at first you know because
obviously this franchise has a massive fan
base to it and it's gonna have like the
story and the horror and a lot of the fun
capitals the characters there's so many things
that you've got to get right but the first thing
that anyone's going to truly judge this movie
on as we know when it comes to adapting IP is
what do the animatronics look like and they they
captured the animatronics perfectly here in my
personal opinion as someone who's only dabbled
with Five Nights at Freddy's and doesn't really
know the lore all that well but speaking of
Lauren all that I'm on the freeze frame here
of Matthew Lillard from the scream franchise
where it says his his name is Steve Ragland
uh but I heard he was playing William Afton who
is the co-owner and the uh like I think the one
responsible for murdering the ghost children
didn't murder you know merge the children
right so I don't know if this is just a cover-up
right yeah yeah if this is just a cover-up or not
um says that I'd like to see the trailers is
totally had me questioning the information that
was communicated my way uh regardless though I am
very excited as screaming being one of my all-time
favorite franchises and screaming my all-time
favorite horror movies to see Matthew Lillard step
back in to this genre because I don't really know
from anything else without a paddle was I hear
that uh maybe then Scooby-Doo never seen it nope
so so yeah but overall I mean I think this trailer
has a really cool hook to it and especially with
finding a way to keep it of real a personal tale
with trying to make sure your sister who you
didn't bring to work doesn't turn into one of
them and having to protect her but this is Five
Nights at Freddy's and I am hoping that it does
end ultimately it seems like with the way the
trailer is progressing that it does end with
her ultimately becoming one of the animatronics
I hope it goes down that path I want to see that
little girl die that is my personal wish I always
root for that that's right little kid murdered
do it you cowards yeah yeah what thoughts do you
have I agree children dying more child murder in
my movies I mean I would be surprised but I mean
it would certainly be a sign that they're willing
to go hard if they take it in that direction and
that kind of reminded me of something that's like
a little bit hearkening to an older kind of
Cinema too you know like the 80s or 90s kind
of thing where it's like yeah this young guy down
on his luck needs a job and he's got to take his
kid sister with him because he's essentially
now the man of the house Etc um and so that's
also a neat way I think to differentiate this from
something like Willie's Wonderland which obviously
you know a certain amount of people even though
Five Nights at Freddy's is like way bigger of a
global phenomenon you know there's still that like
who beat who to the movie punch and I think that's
also where the design uh of the animatronics being
so faithful is another really just lovely thing to
see because yeah like not even being the biggest
expert on the lore in the game or whatever myself
just like seeing those designs and and the fact
that yeah they lend themselves so well to live
action even though part of the whole alloris Scott
coffin's games was the fact that they were made to
look cute and they came out looking creepy just
because that's how his animation is but even
the animatronic layers and then uh and all that
underneath like the way the gears are certainly
like proprietary of the game and uh yeah it looks
appropriately creepy like I like that this trailer
gave us a lot more uh just you know imagery
intensity but it's not really like shining major
light past what the teaser trailer gave us so
there's still a good amount of just like I don't
know like mystery as to like what elements of the
game are going to be really explored through the
plot but you know you've got all the nuts and
bolts right here you know it's clear that we've
got everything that we need for like a chilling
good time and yeah something that looks like it
could play a little bit broadly in terms of like
what ages could get into it without being like for
kids well I'm what I'm really hoping for too is
that they managed to really hone in on the more
simplistic horror elements that the game provided
yeah because this trailer gave us a surprising
amount of exposition and a surprising amount of
explanation as to what's going on like in fact
I was that's the part that surprised me a little
bit is because this story has such a a simple hook
of a person who works a night shift at this kids
this abandoned kids place and then you know like
animatronics come to life it's a haunting it's
like a simple premise of a hook and then they
kind of gave away a lot of the lore already yes
which is something you normally get in a movie way
later like closer towards the finale or something
like that as you're unpacking the mystery yeah and
I think it's something that built over multiple
games too yeah so I really want to experience
the the tension and the horror the actual natural
Hook and the the beginning stages of Five Nights
at Freddy's is the part of it that I feel like is
the thing that you know like you could obviously
take the lore and then you know put it into a
screenplay but the experience the emotional terror
is the thing that I you really gotta experience
yeah that's the part where you know I was like
of course we want to get the lower ride and we
want to get the look right but it's the horror
that you guys want the most attention of looking
at the screens and not running out of flashlights
yeah yeah exactly and where is it going to come
from and yeah like who's sneaking past what camera
is about to jump into this door and you know
devour my soul but either way I'm excited for
Josh Hutcherson to die in this movie he'll die
he won't come back for the sequel but they don't
come back for part three and it'll be awesome
with a big beard if you know it goes and I hope
they do that alrighty guys so what'd you think
about the Five Nights at Freddy's trailer leave
your thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
leave a like also uh let's send this with a
Kevin smart my dude what's really smart is to
spend your night in a janky children's play
place you know break into your local Chuck E
cheese and just you know squat there man you
could probably liven up the you know just
experience of all the people working there
take the animatronics that are there and move
them around you know inhabit their uh visitors
yourself crawl into the gears and walk around and
terrorize the community and that's the way you'll
leave your mark on this that's your child and
then we'll be doing five nights at Kevin's soon
enough you and your kid praise be uh lift up your
hearts we lift them up to the Lord stay holy and
uh we'll we'll catch you soon stay fresh as well
and uh and we won't haunt you so much love be well